talk to me about just this magical day
of being your big debut on the big
screen yeah it's it's crazy in my
element to some extent but I think that
taking on opportunities like this allow
me to grow so much as an artist like I
think that it's good to kind of you know
be scared and and have that feeling like
I don't know if I can do this but you
know I'm not acting in the film
I mean I'm acting I'm acting through my
movements but not with words yes it's a
special story for the ballet world it
was the first ballet I ever saw was the
first ballet I ever danced in so just
made sense you know but to be the
representation for ballet within this
film you know that it's going to reach
so many people that probably don't feel
comfortable stepping into the
Metropolitan Opera House and to be a
black ballerina in this I mean it's just
it's also insane
these young people are gonna look at me
and see a ballerina not a black
ballerina it's gonna be normal and
that's what's so beautiful about badnik
tells the story have to fall around
discovered what was your favorite role
because you've taken on so many
different characters within the
Nutcracker ballet Clara for sure like
I've literally played every role but I
would definitely say that like Clara was
it's my favorite within the ballet but
being the ballerina princess is also
pretty amazing and that's Persian you're
such a trailblazer for so many people
not just in a film but just in this
dance world like you said you've brought
so much representation so I can't wait
to see your beautiful acting through
dance on screen but I do want to talk
about somebody that's been very
influential in your life miss Mariah
Carey you stand for her you stand for
her so talk to me about that like I
don't even know where to begin like you
know I think that it took me until I was
an adult to really understand the impact
she had on me or like why I was so
obsessed with her being someone who's
like I'm representation for so many
people for them to feel like they can do
anything or they can look like anything
and I think maybe subconsciously seeing
a biracial woman Mariah Carey I
connected with her seeing someone so
gifted and succeeding it was like I
connected with all of these things and
her music was just like such a saving
grace for me through extremely difficult
times in my childhood I'm MC she's MC I
have yet like we got we got this thing
like my niece's named Mariah I'm like I
sound like a stalker I swear I'm not
sound like a Finn
[Music]